if the mannequins are 186 centimeters so
they're extra tall so they're kind of
stretched out so chop-chop say it's a
size 10 but yeah really really tall size
10 I thought they looked very thin I
think it's generally a really good
reaction of topshop to change to listen
to their customers and then to alter
their mannequins I don't know what
they're going to look like this is a
problem that we hear about quite often
isn't it when it comes to women who shot
whether it be the size the mannequins
and the mirrors that are stretched to
make you look skinnier in the clothing
and then when you get home you don't the
same as hauling your own realistic
mirror our shops paying attention to
this feedback that they do get quite
often but the same problem seems to crop
up again and again well we saw debenhams
bring in size 16 mannequins and top
shopper gonna listen to this online
complaint so perhaps we are going to see
a difference I'd really like to see a
variety of sizes of mannequins because
let's not forget that topshop customers
are very often young girls
impressionable teens and if they were to
see a variety of body shapes and perhaps
some of those resonated with them that
might be really positive for their body
image want to ring Neil in here you have
a problem is it when a man shopping
because the male mannequins in some of
these shops as well are quite bath you
know there's six foot tall honed body I
can't go anywhere these days without
seeing pictures of David Beckham in his
underpants and the thing about the thing
about this I mean that the original
complaint was that these mannequins
weren't unrealistic mean isn't this a
problem that just crosses the entire
fashion industry there's nothing about
the fashion industry that's about
reality it's about glamorous for
aspiration it's about putting images out
there Oh of a body perfect that must be
fair about so very few bizarre ever
going to achieve even with exercise I
think that is a problem that is seen I
think we are seeing a lot of body image
groups and a lot of online activism
that's really being mobilized to bring
this message to say we want to see a
variety out there and perhaps there is
going to be changed because I do agree
with you there is very often one type of
body that's seen as aspirational which
isn't necessarily achievable for
everybody I mean I mentioned did it
Beckham there that can be precious few
people who are sitting at home right now
you know
wanting to see me in my underpants you
know and whether or not that would have
any effect on on sales I think another
girl from my eve a male in there still
hope don't worry yeah but I mean isn't
that the point though that it is all
about selling something and actually the
consumers is responsible for this as
topshop is but the consumer is speaking
out now and saying that they don't want
to see this and you think it's up to
shops like Topshop to take a stand
because it's all part of a wider culture
at the moment isn't it young girls and
young boys are on Instagram trying to
take the perfect selfie and project this
image that they know they don't look
like that in real life but it's all
about how they portray themselves online
to their friends on social media yes I
suppose it would be really great if
brands like Topshop saw what a huge
influence they have over so many many
young lives and how they see themselves
and I suppose it all comes down to as
someone who has been into topshop a few
times it's all a lot of sizes they stock
as well I mean some of them are quite
frightening they go down to a size 4 but
we must remember that some people are
naturally that shape as well so we can't
have a go at people for being naturally
skinny yeah when I was 15 14 and I was
going to Topshop the sizes were too big
for me I was really skinny people felt
they could take the mickey out of how
skinny I was so it's important to
remember there are there's a variety of
body shapes out there let's perhaps see
them all reflected in the shops and the
magazines and the adverts okay